(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] Rebecca.
- Hi
- [Mark] how are you?
- I'm good.
- [Mark] So nice to see you again.
- So nice to see you.
- [Mark] It's been a long time.
- Definitely.
- [Mark] I haven't seen
you in many months.
- Yeah. How many months has it been?
Like four or five months?
- [Mark] I bet it's been
four or five months. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You doin' all right?
- I'm doing good.
How about you?
- [Mark] I'm doing fine.
What's going on with you?
- Nothing really.
I was just floating around.
- [Mark] Where have you been?
- I've been spending
some time in the Valley
and just kind of running
through the Hills.
You ever heard that song?
I was in Arizona.
And there were these pink, fluffy clouds.
Just be looking at the sky a lot.
(Rebecca chuckles)
Sorry.
- [Mark] Where were you sleeping?
- Anywhere. (chuckles)
- [Mark] Yeah, just same answer. (laughs)
I'm always concerned about
where you're sleeping.
And is your life better?
Is your life worse than
last time I saw you?
- Well, I don't wanna say worse.
Like I said, I got in this car accident.
- [Mark] Tell me about that.
Well, basically it was just
like, it was really freaky.
- [Mark] You're walking?
- So I was walking. Yeah.
And I was trying to, well,
really ironically enough,
I just found a whole bag of shoes.
And as I'm coming to cross the street,
cause I left some
cigarettes with my friend
to give her all these shoes.
This car just comes out of nowhere.
All I remember is somersaulting.
And then I looked down
and my legs snapped.
Then I kept trying to push it back in
and a (chuckles)
and it wouldn't, my bone was
completely stumped in half.
- [Mark] Your leg,
- Yeah. my right leg.
- [Mark] Down there.
- Yeah. Got a scar.
- [Mark] Oh my God. Look at (laughs)
- I think my scar is the most
beautiful thing about me.
(Rebecca laughs)
- [Mark] There's a lot of
beautiful things about you.
But you've healed?
- Yeah. There's pins in my legs.
- [Mark] You have pins in your legs.
- (murmurs)
Was it painful?
No.
It hurts sometimes, but, the surgery,
I didn't feel a thing.
It hurts to walk though.
- [Mark] But you're surviving.
- Thriving.
- [Mark] You're thriving.
(Rebecca laughs)
You seem a little more,
less out of your mind than some
of the other visits you've,
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Grace me with that.
- Maybe more like,
- [Mark] You seem a little more grounded.
- Composed. Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah. Why is that?
- I don't know.
I guess I've just been meditating more.
I've just been more relaxed lately.
Less frenetic.
I don't know.
I guess the seasons,
I feel like,
I don't know, what this
epidemic or, sorry, pandemic.
- [Mark] Yes.
- Everything's so much more relaxed.
So I'm just wandering
streets more at night.
More taking long walks.
Then I am like, partying.
- [Mark] Is COVID effecting you?
- Yes and no.
I feel like I'm kind of,
I don't know how to put it.
COVID proves that the system works.
Everyone just bought into
it automatically like that.
I don't know how I feel
about being on the fringe anymore
because it makes me feel like so much more
of an outcast.
Because I'm not in the fervor
of it.
I don't,
- [Mark] You're not running around scared.
I'm not scared because
there was swine flu,
there was bird flu.
I feel like fear feeds fear.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You know, we have nothing
to fear but fear itself.
- [Mark] But there are
people dying from it.
- It's awful, unfortunately.
- [Mark] Somewhere, hospitals where,
- [Mark] There are people
dying of starvation all over.
(Rebecca laughs)
Have you talked with your family at all?
- No.
- [Mark] No.
- No. I barely got to hold on to a phone.
- [Mark] Oh.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you have friends?
- I have friends. Yeah.
- [Mark] You do. So you're not lonely.
- I'm not lonely.
- [Mark] You're just drifting around and,
- Yeah. I like doing that.
I don't know why I like doing it.
- [Mark] Yeah. You're happy.
You seem happy.
- Yeah. But I feel like I
need to judge myself for it.
I don't.
It's so convenient when it's just me.
It's the minute I have to
give it a context, you know?
- [Mark] But you like this
life of no responsibility?
- I do. I hate that I
love it so much but I do.
- [Mark] You think you've
gained some weight?
- Yeah. A little bit.
Cause they had me in physical therapy
so I was like laying in bed for a month.
- [Mark] Oh, that'll do it.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I like your outfit.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Where'd you get
them? Where'd you find them?
- Found it on the floor.
(Mark laughs)
- I found this on the floor
and I found this,
it was just sitting there on a bridge.
I had it like a cloak, like
I had it like a druid cloak.
And then I turned it and
burned it into a skirt.
- [Mark] You sure did.
You always come up with
something creative.
(Rebecca laughs)
So what's your plan for the holidays?
- I have no idea.
No idea.
You don't really celebrate
holidays very often
living the way I do. You know what I mean?
- [Mark] No, you don't.
- Every day is a celebration.
- Every day is,
(both laughing)
- Every day is an excuse.
- [Mark] So you had an auto accident.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What's the best
thing that's happened to you
since I saw you last?
- I met this Rockefeller.
I spent the night with him.
He was really weird.
He was really weird, but he was great.
I don't know if I wanna
talk about it too much.
- [Mark] Don't talk about it too much.
- It was like one of those
things, you know what I mean?
Like a conspiracy, like a hush hush thing.
- [Mark] Yeah. You don't need to,
- Although, you know,
- [Mark] We don't need to
get anybody in hot water.
- Yeah.
(Rebecca laughs)
- But yeah. Just call him Mr. Rockefeller.
And he was,
he was very, you know when people,
I never understood the word visionary
until I met that person.
'Cause
it's like real estate.
Like I could never understand commodity,
and this person helped me understand
what it is to have
more than you know what to do with.
And I liked that
The stuff he said to me was incredible.
- [Mark] You're learning things?
You're growing as a person?
- Yes. Growing from love.
I can't remember what
that's from. (chuckles)
Yes. I'm a budding blossom
of a beautiful petunia.
- [Mark] You're certainly interesting.
- Thank you.
I get lots of interesting
people in front of my cameras.
You're somewhere at the top of the list.
(Rebecca laughs)
- I don't believe that for a second.
I've seen some of the people,
I found your page finally.
I think the people that you
find it very interesting.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I feel like I'm quite down,
- [Mark] I'm really lucky.
- Yeah.
[Mark]Did you watch your videos?
- I did. Yeah.
- [Mark] What do you think of yourself?
- I am strange. (chuckles)
I like it though.
- [Mark] Yeah. Strange.
There's nothing wrong with strange.
- Nothing wrong with strange.
I'm more strange than I am weird.
It just make me feel me.
I feel like a stranger for myself.
I'm just gonna separate it.
- [Mark] I just find you interesting.
I see tons of potential in you
but
how we're gonna
make that turn into something
productive, I don't know.
Maybe you don't want to.
- It's not that I don't want to.
I just have no clue as to,
there's certain things I wanna go about
but I feel so separated from them.
And it's not just 'cause
of living the way I do.
I just, like you said responsibility.
I have no sense of
responsibility whatsoever.
I have
no sense of
entitlement to anything.
So it's hard to weigh myself down
to need things, you know?
So I guess I don't have that,
but I do want it, I suppose.
- [Mark] Do you have
any goals for next year?
New year's resolutions?
Anything?
- To be a better witch. (chuckles)
- To be a better witch.
(Mark laughs)
- I think 2021's gonna be
very similar to 2020 for you.
- Yeah.
- 2020 was strange.
You can think of polarity or duality.
Like at the beginning of the
year was so intense for me
and then the end of the
year, it was really calm.
But I just wonder if it means anything.
Things will just have to
mean something, you know?
(motorcycle roaring)
- [Mark] I just want you to be happy.
And you seem to be happy.
- I am happy.
- [Mark] Do you have
moments where you're down?
- Of course. Who doesn't?
- [Mark] Yeah. Everybody does.
No, but you,
I've only seen you one
time where you were down.
- But I feel like I know
how to be satisfied.
Yeah, that's true.
I was, yeah.
I was really out of it that day.
What was going on that day?
I just kind of gotten rough about,
so, having that, you know what I mean?
It wasn't even in Skid Row,
it was really weird part.
It was an odd, was like
a really nice area.
- [Mark] No, but get getting
roughed up on the street.
It's gotta be very disconcerting.
- Well, disconcerting (chuckles)
it's a fact of it. Isn't it?
It's supposed to be the
all giving fact of it.
It's what people wanna see.
- [Mark] What's the worst thing
about living on the street?
- I'm suffering.
Help me.
You know what I mean?
Like, (chuckles)
I don't know.
- [Mark] Everybody feel sorry for you?
- Pretension. Yeah.
It's not that I mind who have
been feeling sorry for me.
I just mind people feeling
bad for me in an abrasive way.
Like
people who give you a
certain sort of attention
It's not just like, what
the fuck are you wearing?
But let's say, let's
take that as an example.
Okay. Keep it pushing.
You will feel really
entitled to a piece of you
because you're so,
because I can,
it seems like I have it to give away
- [Mark] But there are people
kind and generous with you?
- Yeah.
They see you in the street,
they say, here's money for food
or here's some whatever.
- Sometimes, yeah.
- [Mark] 'Cause you're not
really collecting money
from anything or you're not panhandling.
You're not doing anything.
- I panhandle sometimes.
- [Mark] You do?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I can't picture you panhandling.
- [Rebecca] It looks really funny.
It's kind of like,
I have tactics.
I'll be like,
"Excuse me, sorry.
Please can you help me
get something to eat?"
I'm actually really polite
and friendly about it.
I don't like flying a sign
because I don't like sitting
in one place for too long.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Rebecca] Back up to
people at McDonald's
and just asking money, food.
- [Mark] Did you find the shop owners
and people like that are fairly kind and,
- [Rebecca] No one treats me badly.
I don't know if it's
because of how I dressed
or how I am.
Or maybe because my
tone's a little softer.
- [Mark] Yeah. You don't
look like you're trouble.
- [Rebecca] Well, it's not like a,
- [Mark] You're a little
bit nutty, but you're not,
- [Rebecca] I went to
Fendi like a month ago
and I remember they told me I smelled bad.
But then I went to Chanel and
they let me try on clothes.
It was really weird.
- [Mark] Chanel let you try on clothes?
- [Rebecca] Yeah. They
let me try on clothes.
(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] That's pretty cool.
- [Rebecca] Yeah. I was shaved.
I shaved that day on Melrose.
I like Melrose.
- [Mark] Well, you're very
handsome and clean shaven.
You probably come off,
like you might be just an eccentric,
- [Rebecca] I could actually
be something of myself
if I shave.
I should get that electrolysis
done on the beard.
I just don't like that I have facial hair.
But it's one of those things,
- [Mark] You should be
eccentric millionaire
with that shoes.
- [Rebecca] Yes.
I'd be an eccentric
millionaire with that shoes.
I am an eccentric
Thinking is being.
You're going to Memphis.
I really love,
I love Cajun culture.
It's so different from out here.
- [Mark] Very different.
- I love swamps.
- [Mark] Louisiana is a great state.
- When I was in New Orleans,
I spent a lot of time at swamps.
And just, like you said, like hillbillies.
I love hillbillies.
Oh, there's new movies coming out called,
This movie coming out is
called Hillbilly Elegy.
- [Mark] Yeah. I've heard of it.
- I like that.
I like that you can give something,
It's like dignity, like
that's what you do.
You know what I mean?
You give things dignity
in a really,
but in a nice way.
In a confusing way, but in a nice way.
- [Mark] I try to be
respectful of everyone.
- But it gives hillbilly substance.
It was like that movie Winter's Bone.
It gives them a being, you know?
Cause I love Appalachia.
I love like,
I feel like that's so separated
from American culture.
- [Rebecca] Very different.
Yeah. Because it's not as,
- [Mark] It's like another country.
- It's not like, it's not Chinese.
I don't know how to say it.
It's not as like factory farm.
- [Mark] No, there are no
chain restaurants or stores or anything.
It's just, there might be a gas station
within 50 miles away.
- You know what I mean?
There are places like that.
And I love that.
People who maybe don't
appreciate the midst
of where they are.
- [Mark] Yeah. You know,
every time I come back from there,
I'd have a whole new appreciation for
- modern convenience?
- [Mark] Yes. It's just like,
oh my God this is such a different world.
- You got bad cell service?
- [Mark] There is no cell service.
- There's no cell service. (chuckles)
- [Mark] No, there's
no cell service there.
You have to drive to one of
the larger cities to get,
- Oh God. Wow.
- [Mark] Yeah.
I'm unreachable when I'm there.
- Well, there you go.
- [Mark] I can't do anything.
(metal hitting)
Yeah. It's very, very isolated
in all kinds of different ways.
- But that's a good thing.
Or it can be.
- [Mark] Yeah. I'm obviously
fascinated with it.
I'm sure I'll be back again
when the weather warms up.
I hate the cold so I'm gonna avoid it.
- I hate the cold.
That's why I'm in LA.
So I'm in California.
I love the weather.
- [Mark] We're talking about Florida
before we started shooting.
Oh, the air in Florida.
- [Mark] You and I both love Florida.
- I love Florida.
I don't know why.
- [Mark] Yeah. There's
something about Florida
that's really great.
- Yeah. It's really loopy.
(Mark laughs)
You know,
people are kind of
wired differently there.
Of Miami
People really know how to party in Miami.
I feel like people don't
know how to party in LA.
People know how to party in Miami.
- I bet you you're fun to party with.
(Rebecca chuckles)
- The life of the party.
Take risks.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Risks are a great thing.
- Are you fun to party with, Mark?
- [Mark] Well, I mean,
what do you mean by party?
Cause I'm not a get drunk and smoke weed.
- I don't smoke weed.
- [Mark] I'm not a
dancer. I'm not a drinker
or a smoker, so.
But I have fun, like, all the time.
I have more fun than anybody.
I'm having more fun than anyone I know,
but I'm never drinking or
smoking or going to parties.
But doing this project is so much fun.
- There's been no
parties because of COVID.
Yeah. I can imagine you
enjoying what you do.
- [Mark] This has been the
best year of my life, I think.
- How long have you been doing this for?
- [Mark] A year and a half.
Hot and heavy, I've been doing it for 10.
But 10 and I got divorced
and then I started again,
and I stopped and I started and I stopped.
The last year and a half has
been pretty much everyday.
And I love it.
(Mark laughs)
I don't see myself stopping.
- Yeah. That's great.
I wish I had that devotion or something.
- [Mark] I think it's
the key to happiness.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I was thinking
about this the other day.
That so many people are focused
on winning, or achieving,
or not achieving winning.
Like if I won the lottery,
or if I got a great job
and made lots of money,
or if I had a great house, a great car,
great whatever, I'd be happy.
And I see so clearly
how that means nothing.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It's
It's conquering your fears
that makes you happy.
- I think it's the idea of,
- [Mark] Cause if you
really wanna be happy,
truly fulfilled, and like,
wow, I'm having a great
week, day, month. whatever, year.
If you're conquering your fears,
you're gonna feel that way.
Whereas if you won the lottery,
three weeks later you're
like, you've lost a lot
- Yeah, lottery winners always
end up really messed up.
- [Mark] They lose
their friends and family
and they're broken.
- They lose everything. Yeah.
- [Mark] It's not the key to happiness.
Money is not gonna make you happy.
You think it would
- It's not about money or material things.
It's about finding
things you actually love.
Some people are so focused on an end game.
You know what I mean?
They'll be like, oh, in 20
years I wanna have $50 million.
Okay. But then once you get there,
you're old and decrepit and your fat.
And you know, you're
having fuck a 20 year old
Russian hooker 'cause nobody loves you.
It's not that you lose your soul,
You just,
there's no,
the purpose behind it is very lofty.
You know.
- [Mark] You've mentioned
risk a little while ago.
And risk and fear and courage
are all kind of closely tied.
They're all related.
And they're all basically
the same thing to me.
And
so many people are risk
averse and I'm the opposite.
Like, if I find something,
and I'm not saying stupid risks
but risks that are,
if they work out and if you have,
if they're dependent on
courage and conquering fears
then that's a risk I'd love to take.
- Yeah.
You ever been mountain
climbing or anything like that?
- [Mark] It's not my thing.
- I kind of have a fear of heights.
- [Mark] Yeah. I mean,
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Like conquering
fears and doing things
that are really does
scare the crap out of me,
I do all the time.
But I'm not gonna go parachuting or
bungee jumping or climbing
mountains or like that.
- I feel like things irritate
me more than I fear them.
Like pain, pain is annoying to me.
It's an inconvenience.
It's an inconvenience of being, you know.
I wonder if there's a way you
could rewrite laws of nature.
Like, you know, they say
the law of attraction
or the law of gravity.
What if you made it illegal to feel pain?
You know, people will think
of suffering or misery
or sadness, but I think of pain.
I just wonder.
It was just one of those things.
- Well, I think one of
those laws of the universe
is for every negative, there's a positive.
Like, so you broke your leg
and there's something
positive from that experience.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] There's something
positive that came from that.
Getting hit by car and breaking your legs.
Like maybe you're gonna
live more precautiously.
And that might be a good thing for you.
Or you might,
the time you spent in the
hospital might've made you wake up
to something that you didn't
realize about yourself
or the way you're living or,
there's always a positive.
- Oh, there's a lot of
reality TV. (chuckles)
(Mark laughs)
But yeah, there is always, you know,
they say silver lining.
- [Mark] Well, Rebecca,
it's so great seeing you.
What a great surprise.
- [Rebecca] Thank you.
- [Mark] I'm packing up
and going to the airport
and then you showed up.
(Rebecca chuckles)
- [Rebecca] Yeah. I really
seek for fitting me in.
- [Mark] Well, take take care of yourself.
- [Rebecca] I will.
- [Mark] I hope you come
back many more times.
- I hope so too.
- [Mark] You're okay?
- [Rebecca] Yeah. I'm great.
I'm great.
- [Mark] You are great.
(both laughing)
You're really great.
- [Rebecca] Thanks.
Okay. We'll talk soon.
- [Rebecca] Okay.
- [Mark] Thanks.